foreign
[Music]
next 2022.
you're in three gke app development
strategies to help teams deliver their
best work
I'm kazlyn fields and I'm a developer
advocate here at Google Cloud where I
focus on Google kubernetes engine as
well as open source kubernetes
and today we're going to be talking
about application development and
kubernetes first we're going to break
down the problem and then we're going to
go over three patterns that I commonly
see companies adopting as they adopt
kubernetes within their organizations
and how those patterns affect their
application Developers
so let's start by breaking down the
problem
to break down the problem we need to
know what is the question we're trying
to answer
as an advocate for Google clouds and
particularly gke's users I interact with
a lot of companies adopting kubernetes
and almost every single one of them is
asking me this question
the words vary but the point is always
the same how are the lives of my
application developers going to change
as we adopt kubernetes
I call this the kubernetes app Dev
experience question and it has three
basic parts
first the organization is adopting a
tool kubernetes they're asking about a
specific audience people in the role of
app developer and what they want to know
is how the tool kubernetes is going to
affect the day-to-day tasks of the folks
in the app Dev role
and always keep in mind that a
business's goal is ultimately to deliver
value to their own users so the
overarching frame this question fits
into is some approximation of the
software delivery process
the business wants to run apps that are
critical to them sometimes that's apps
they built sometimes they're apps they
got from elsewhere but ultimately the
tools roles and tasks involved are all
trying to accomplish the goal of running
those important applications and to
answer this question we really do need
to get to this level of the root of the
question and I'll show you why
so let's start by diving a little deeper
into the software delivery process
this is a diagram we sometimes use at
Google Cloud to talk about the tools we
have available that enable each stage of
the software delivery process
from writing code to getting the
applications running in production to
monitoring those production applications
these processes roughly align with two
broad roles
developers who write and maintain app
code and operations professionals who
run those applications in production and
other environments
there are all kinds of specific roles
within the Spectrum and where one ends
and another begins varies quite a lot
from one company to another
it's like a gradient it's hard to tell
where one role might end and another
begin
but what does this have to do with
active experience on kubernetes
the traditional realm of app developers
is pretty solidly on what I have as
colored blue in this gradient
app developers are in charge of writing
and maintaining app code
and to do so they use tools like
integrated development environments and
Source control tools this is pretty
standard anywhere you go
but today we're also going to be talking
about kubernetes and if you'll notice
kubernetes on our chart is pretty far
toward the operation side of the house
this is why the question of what does
the app developer experience look like
with kubernetes is actually kind of hard
to answer traditionally kubernetes has
been created by and for operations
professionals so often when this
question comes up the folks who have
been the deepest in the kubernetes
ecosystem who helped create kubernetes
have tended to respond with well
developers shouldn't care about
kubernetes at all
but is that really true it kind of looks
that way from this chart doesn't it
this is where devops comes into the
picture so what is devops
devops is the organizational and
cultural movement meaning it affects how
your roles relate to the ownership of
tasks that need doing
that aims to increase software delivery
velocity so that's kind of more to the
dev side
improve service reliability that's kind
of site reliability engineer like so
kind of more to the op side
and most importantly to build shared
ownership among software stakeholders
so you might not have known it but what
you've just asked is a devops question
what this means is that even though
kubernetes was designed by in four
operations professionals due to the
shift toward more shared ownership
models the answer to how is my app Dev
experience going to change with
kubernetes is Maybe
kubernetes might affect your app
developer's day-to-day lives but as with
any good question in Tech the real
answer is it depends it depends on what
parts of this process your app
developers have ownership of
ultimately the tasks your app devs are
expected to own will determine what
tools they need to use
so for the rest of this talk I'm going
to explore the three most common
patterns I see organizations adopting
with regard to app development with
kubernetes
each of these patterns introduces a bit
more devopsy style ownership into app
developers lives many organizations I
speak to are on a path where they move
from pattern one toward pattern three
over time
most large organizations will probably
have spots within their orgs that
Implement each one of these patterns
there's no one right answer to how your
app developer experience should be as
you adopt kubernetes it will depend on
how you want to distribute tasks and
ownership of the software delivery
process among the roles in your
organization
we're focused on application developers
as the only role we're talking about
today so I'll explore the tasks and
tools your organization might assign to
your application developers in each one
of these patterns so let's dive into
each one
to start let's talk about what I call
the traditional local development
pattern
in traditional local development app
dev's own tasks up to the point where
code is checked in and ready to be
handed off to teams that will build and
run that code in the necessary
environments the delivery artifact for
these developers is source code
they write code check it into Source
control and that's pretty much where
their ownership ends that code will
still need to be built and deployed into
onto Hardware but those responsibilities
are not owned by the average developer
this is how most organizations have
traditionally scoped the application
developer type role
the tools these developers typically use
haven't really changed too terribly much
over the last couple decades
your app devs will need an integrated
development environment or IDE they'll
need some form of source control to
collaboratively work on large code bases
they'll need to learn some sort of
programming language or maybe a few and
they'll need to get familiar with
libraries both public and private code
libraries that they'll be using to build
the applications your business needs
this pattern also has a benefit in terms
of environment flexibility
since your app Dev teams delivery
artifact is source code
it could be run on any number of types
of environments you could run this code
on VMS or on kubernetes or on serverless
or on just about anything
all of that is determined by other teams
after the handoff
so you can run the code just about
wherever depending on what the code is
Without Really impacting your app Dev
team's day-to-day lives
so the traditional local development
pattern keeps you pretty solidly on the
left side of our ownership spectrum of
the software delivery process
this is the type of development role
that most people are thinking about if
they come back at your kubernetes app
development experience question with app
devs shouldn't care about kubernetes at
all
in this pattern with the way the world
has been that's been kind of true
kubernetes was designed as a tool for
folks who run code in various
environments it has nothing to do with
the writing of pure application code
so developers in this pattern would
typically complete their application
code and hand it off to some other team
which might containerize it and run it
on kubernetes
because kubernetes does require that app
code be packaged in containers but
asking some other team that didn't write
the code to package that code in a
container
can be kind of tough sometimes
the whole idea of containers is that the
application code and all those binaries
and libraries that it needs are packaged
up together and who knows those
dependencies better than the app Dev
team that wrote the thing so that brings
us to pattern two
development in containers in the
development in containers pattern
application developers take on the
additional responsibility of packaging
their application code along with any
and all dependencies into containers the
delivery artifact of your app Dev teams
shifts from source code to container
files or container images you might
think of a container image like a binary
file of a traditional application it's
the compiled form of the package
containing your app and its dependencies
that can be run as a container
the application developers and
organizations that have adopted this
pattern need some additional tools
they'll still need Ides Source control
and a solid understanding of their
required programming languages but
they'll also need containerization
tooling the tools to perform
containerization at scale really started
to be publicly available and to gain
popularity starting in 2014. so the
developer Tools in this space are
generally less than a decade old though
they're built on older Concepts
the most common tool most folks have
heard of is of course docker I like to
say that Docker is a usability company
they didn't invent containers but they
did invent the usability tooling that
has led to Containers current popularity
but docker's tools are not the only
options these days the tools in bold
here are things that Google Cloud could
help you with
Cloud native build packs is an open
source project of the cloud native
Computing foundation and it allows you
to and a quote from their website
transform your application source code
into images that can run on any cloud
Google Cloud supports Cloud native build
packs meaning we have provided tooling
to help developers containerize their
applications via Cloud native build
packs
Google Cloud also has a tool called
Google Cloud build which you can use to
build a container image and other things
like Java archives to be stored in a
registry like Google Cloud's artifact
registry
so the development in containers pattern
moves your app Dev teams ownership a
little farther toward the op side of our
diagram and it's not that these pieces
become wholly owned by your app Dev
teams but you're leaning into building
this devops style shared ownership model
operations teams will probably still
have responsibilities around
configuration and ownership of these
tools as well essentially what you're
doing here is you're getting your
application development teams a little
bit more involved in the build process
the build steps of your software
delivery process
this pattern does start to get into
changes to your application developers
day-to-day lives when you're adopting
kubernetes but it doesn't directly have
anything to do with kubernetes itself
organizations that don't use kubernetes
could also see benefits from adopting
this pattern of app Dev
since containers themselves provide nice
benefits as a packaging and isolation
mechanism for your applications
organizations that start using them
could see other benefits even if they're
not using kubernetes though if you're
running things at scale you're probably
going to want to use kubernetes
but if you're sitting there going yeah
but is that really kubernetes app Dev
experience don't they need to know about
kubernetes itself to some degree
then pattern three might be what you're
looking for
in pattern three we explore an even more
involved approach developing directly on
kubernetes
in this pattern application developers
own the tasks of patterns one and two
completing code check-ins and
containerizing their application code
and they pick up the additional
responsibility of understanding
kubernetes enough to Define how their
containerized applications should run on
kubernetes by writing kubernetes
declarative yaml manifests
these manifests are key to the
beneficial declarative nature of
kubernetes
the yaml manifests describe the
container as well as details about how
that container should be run in an
environment things like storage and
networking configurations are built into
the API of objects provided by
kubernetes
in Pattern 2 some form of more opsy team
would take the containers made by the
app devs and write these kubernetes yaml
files to describe how the app should be
run in kubernetes
but in this pattern we're once again
asking the folks who know the
application the best to put that
knowledge to use by defining exactly how
that application should run on
kubernetes
the tools of these developers will grow
in addition to all the tools of patterns
one and two these devs also need things
like a kubernetes environment to test
and develop in
this could be a local environment via
minicube which is an open source
component of the kubernetes project
Google has a number of Engineers
dedicated to maintaining and improving
mini Cube so I've bolded it here even
though it's really part of it when
source kubernetes
this could also be a gke cluster in
Google cloud or an anthos cluster in a
variety of possible environments
including on-prem or in other clouds
Google Cloud also provides a really
handy IDE plugin called Cloud code which
provides in my honest opinion amazing
support for working with either local or
remote kubernetes environments right
from within an IDE
a with Visual Studio code but it's also
available for the jetbrains IDE
Google also open sourced a project
called scaffold which and I once again
quote from their website
handles the workflow for building
pushing and deploying your application
allowing you to focus on what matters
most writing code
so Cloud code is designed with lots of
nice scaffold integration that can allow
you to write your code and run it either
in a local or a remote kubernetes
cluster as smoothly as you'd normally
build an application code in like a
traditional development model
also I want to mention that the cloud
native Computing Foundation offers a
certification for developers with this
level of ownership
it's called the certified kubernetes
application developer exam and the exam
itself is a Hands-On test that tests
your knowledge of writing manifests to
run applications on kubernetes
so the developing directly on kubernetes
pattern moves your app Dev team's
ownership even farther toward the upside
of our diagram your application
developers are taking on additional
responsibilities that have traditionally
been in the Ops environment managed
sphere of ownership
again this is a shared ownership model
where these pieces likely still need
operations team ownership as well
the shared ownership model where devs
use kubernetes directly means your app
developers will likely need to gain
knowledge about how these environments
work
they may not have had to worry about
Enterprise scale storage and networking
considerations before so they may need
to learn a bit about how those things
work in the frame of kubernetes I would
caution that kubernetes is a large
complex tool meant to provide tooling
for management and abstraction of
underlying infrastructure so you may
want to be careful to make sure that
your devs are learning about the bits of
kubernetes that make the most sense for
them to use there's plenty of more Ops
oriented stuff in there that they may
not really need but your Ops teams might
so that's the three most common patterns
I see businesses today implementing with
regard to their app development on
kubernetes
which one is right for you depends on
how you want to distribute tasks and
ownership to the various roles in your
organization
if you want to keep app devs focused on
code and have them
just commit their code to Source control
and then have someone else basically
handle everything else then that's
pattern one
if you want your app devs to start
containerizing their applications to
package them with their dependencies and
make them easier for other teams to run
on a variety of systems that's pattern
two
and if you want your developers to own
everything from how that app works to
its packaging to how it's going to be
run in a kubernetes environment then
pattern three is for you
definitely take a deeper look at the
tools I mentioned here such as build
packs and Cloud code to learn more
thanks so much for joining me today and
I hope you enjoy Google Cloud next 2022
[Music]